getting your children to eat healthier
isn't always easy but with childhood
obesity at record high levels is
important this mother of two admits
getting the right balance is a learning
curve if I think to myself look we're
gonna go out for a walk I'm gonna go for
a run they're gonna come with me
that's really really important because
if I think well do you know what I'm not
going to do that then I'm pretty damn
sure that the kids probably won't want
to do that either
so everything in moderation we all love
a treat we were like a bit of sugar and
a cake and a bit of fast food but it has
to be balanced and it has to be I think
a bit of a tree running might not always
be what she wants to do but Joe gets her
daughter and son exercising by doing it
as a team they're looking for their
beatbox there it is over there
and as he notices they'll be looking at
their phones in South London a doctor
had the same idea and devised again to
get children moving critical of the
government strategy to tackle obesity
William Byrd came up with beat the
street where kids and adults tap in at
various boxes around a town to gain
points a GP for 25 years he says he's
worried about the impact obesity is
already having on the future health of
children what happens in cells of fat
cells particularly the ones in the tummy
they create this inflammation this
inflammation starts to attack the brain
it starts to attack arteries and that
leads to diabetes dementia even and
depression anxiety cardiovascular
disease all those conditions that we get
all start off in children and it's such
a progression all the way through and
that's what I feel is such a worry it's
a problem that didn't exist 50 years ago
though some children eating an extra 500
calories a day
the result is alarming almost 10% of 4
to 5 year olds in England are obese when
they reach 10 to 11 years old that
number has doubled to 20% and a child is
more than twice as likely to be obese if
they come from a deprived family across
the country more initiatives are in
place to address obesity head-on
choice with you through there have a
sticker in this school in stoke-on-trent
lunchboxes are monitored for unhealthy
food you've got to try and make hundred
Leila and math lessons now take place in
the Sports Hall and we've tried to put
in initiatives across the whole school
day to make sure that they are up and
moving so they're getting that healthy
active lifestyle to generate their brain
activity as well and just to help them
realize that it's good to be up and
about and active during the day but
schools alone cannot solve the country's
obesity crisis the people seeing the
problem firsthand say the government
strategy needs to be stronger you could
have been a lot better a lot a lot more
structured and lot more connected to
everything so we really get the
transport in education and the parks and
the and business and everyone pulling
together these is our generation coming
through this is our future
and we seem to have just pushed it into
the side the number of children leaving
primary school obese is on the rise
those on the front line say action on a
much greater scale is needed to stop the
problem where it starts Charlotte Lomas
Sky News